S
THE RECESSION, AND VENDOR HEADS
OVER A MORNING SHOW SEEN
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
HAPPENING?
MY.
>> STILL AT THESE NUMBERS,
THEY SEEM TO BE LINING UP FAIRLY
WELL FOR JOE BIDEN IF A DECISIVE
ONE FOR THE ELECTION IN 24.
THE INFLATION, AND SOME OF THE
RECESSIONARY PROBLEMS, THEY GET
WASHED OUT AND 23 AND BY 24, IT
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE MOVING TO
WHERE WE WERE IN 1994.
>> OH, MY GOSH, OUR NEXT GUEST
SAY THAT THIS COMPARISON IS
LAUGHABLE, AS REMEMBER WHAT
REAGAN WAS DOING IN THE EARLY
80s ONE COUNTER TO EVERY
LIBERAL PRESCRIPTION BEING
PRESENTED.
HERE NOW IS THE FORMER CHAIR OF
ACCOUNTS OF ECONOMIC ECONOMIC
ADVISORS IN THE TRUNK, AND WHO
RECITATION FELLOW, KEVIN,
EXPLAIN FIVE VIEWERS WHILE
COMPARING BIOTIN TO GRADE AGAIN,
IT IS ABSURD.
THE WORD IS AN ABSURD IT'S
FARCICAL.
>> YES, IT'S AN ABSOLUTE JOKE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS REAGAN CAME
IN WITH THOUGHTS OF INFLATION
JUST LIKE BIOTIN.
WHAT HE DID -- BIDEN KICKED IT
OFF AT THE SPENDING, BUT WHAT
REAGAN DID WAS WENT FOR KICKED
OFF HE HAD A SUPPLY TAX COOKS SO
THEY WERE MORE SUPPLIES AND A
CUT GOVERNMENT SPENDING, AND NOT
THINK I SCARED SPENDING BY 22%.
ELEVATING THE SENATE HIKED TAXES
AND INCREASED GOVERNMENT
SPENDING SO A SPEEDING COMMAND
BY SECURING SUPPLIES.
AND THAT IS IN A MAKE INFLATION
WORSE AND WORSE.
SO YOU KNOW, EVEN THE LENTEN
LIBERAL ECONOMISTS ARE SAVED IT
AND IT IS NOT TO GET BETTER
INTENTION.
SO, THEY ARE NOT REALLY PASSING
THE CLASS RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL YEAH BIDEN'S DEPUTY
TREASURER AND SECRETARY SAYS
THAT EVERYTHING IS PRETTY MUCH
PQ WATCH.
>> WITH A BIT ABOUT THE U.S.
ECONOMY, WE STILL SEE A GREAT
DEAL OF MOMENTUM IN TERMS OF
CONSUMER DEMANDS STRONG.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
TWO WEEKS WE HAD A CHANCE TO SIT
DOWN WITH CEOs ARE TELLING ME
FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE IF THEY
ARE STILL GETTING ORDERS FROM
CONSUMERS OR OTHER BUSINESSES,
AND THEY FEEL GOOD ABOUT THEIR
ORDER BOOKS.
>> CAMPAIGN, I THINK I'VE EVER
SEEN THEM BEFORE, WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING HEARING FROM BUSINESS
LEADERS?
>> LOW, BUSINESS LEADERS ARE
AFRAID THAT THEY SAY IT
RECESSION COMING, WE JUST
CURRENTLY SAID SALES DATA IS
THAT WE STILL TEN TO NOVEMBER.
AND THE SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR
WHEN I CAN HAVE A NEGATIVE PACK
THAT WE HAD THE FIRST HALF.
WE DEFTLY HAD A RECESSION IN THE
FACE OF THE YEAR, BUT THE
CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN BORROWING ON
THEIR CREDIT CARDS LIKE CRAZY.
CREDIT CARD DEBT IS UP 50%
RELATIVE LAST YEAR, AND THERE'S
NO WAY THEY CAN BE ABLE TO
BORROW AGAIN NEXT YEAR BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL WITH INTEREST RATE
GOING UP AND HAVE TO PAY MORE
FOR THE CREDIT CARD DEBT.
THE SECOND ABOUT THEIR HEATING
AND LIMITS.
SO CONSUMPTION HAS GOT TO HIT A
WALL AS WE GO TO NEXT YEAR WHICH
IS WHY ALL THE WALL STREET
ECONOMIES ARE SAYING THAT WE CAN
HAVE A SESSION.
SO I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHERE
HE'S COMING FROM.
AND SECRETARY ALSO HAD A PIECE
OF "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
WERE BRAGGING ABOUT THE ECONOMY
AND AT PEACE THAT WILL CONDUCT A
HOT OR SOON.
>> YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS
IN OUR PODCAST, BUT I WOULD
EXPAND ON THIS BECAUSE YOUR
POINT, ABOUT WHAT REPUBLICANS,
ESPECIALLY IN ANY SANE DEMOCRATS
LAST WANT TO SAVE THIS COUNTRY'S
ECONOMY WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING RATHER THAN THIS OMNIBUS
BILL, AS HARD AS IT WOULD BE
P.R. LIES IN THE TERM EXPLAINED
THAT FOR THE VIEWERS.
>> THE REPUBLICANS WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO IS TO HAVE A REAL,
REAL HARD LOOK AT SHUTTING DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT AND CUTTING
SPENDING AN ENORMOUS LEAD THE
WAY RONALD REAGAN DID.
YOU KNOW THE HOUSE HAS THE POWER
OF THE PURSE, AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO SAY WHEN THEY DO THAT
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T REALLY
THREATEN THE DEAD OF THE U.S.
WITH THE SHUTDOWN OF IT SO SCARY
NUMBER SO RESPONSIBLE FOR HOW
IRRESPONSIBLE IS IT THAT WE NOW
ALL A WHOLE YEAR'S GDP.
MOSTLY TO THE CHINESE AND OTHER
FOREIGN INVESTORS BECAUSE OF
THESE RECKLESS POLICIES.
IN OTHER THE FORECASTED GHOSTED
TO DDP'S TWO YEARS OF DOING GDP,
SO I THINK IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO
SPEND THE WAY THEY ARE DOING.
TO BE IRRESPONSIBLE FOR
REPUBLICANS TO PLAY ALONG.
>> KEVIN, THIS IS SOBERING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH